iconic landmarks like New York's Empire
State Building went dark to show
solidarity the Eiffel Tower in Paris and
Rome's Coliseum that you see there also
turned off their lights we also saw the
Orlando Eye Ferris wheel was illuminated
with the colors of the British flag and
in Dubai the Burj Khalifa the world's
tallest building was lit up look at this
with the Union Jack beautifully done
welcome back to CBS this morning a lot
of news ahead the head of Manchester's
police is thinking the city's residents
were their response to the bombing at a
vigil yesterday Chief Constable in
Hopkins said first responders are
heartened by how people United them
thousands turned out to honor the
victims Jonathan Vigliotti shows us how
residents are stepping up during one of
Manchester's darkest hours Jonathan good
morning good morning nor the people are
Manchester have tremendous courage and a
sense of unity in the immediate
aftermath of this attack many stepped in
to help just last night we saw a long
line of cars outside one of the
hospitals so drivers we spoke with we're
bringing clothes to donate to the
victims inside this is a strong City and
the people that we have spoken with say
they will rise up
by the thousands they came not only to
mourn the victims but to also send a
message to terrorists you cannot defeat
us because love in the end is always
stronger than hate that love was on
display almost immediately after the
explosion I heard tremendous stories of
doctors coming in to support of police
officers ambulance workers giving up
their days and turning up those in need
I just got as many as I could in the
back of the car and got them away taxi
driver saff Ismail was near the arena
when the bomb exploded an attack is some
people would drive away from that but
you didn't you didn't I was it was at
work
but and also I saw people coming out and
I'm thinking I've got to try and get
them away if there's something happening
he ferried about two dozen people from
the arena many of them he said reminded
him of his 15 year old daughter she was
supposed to go to was supposed to go but
she changed mind a couple months ago
cause she had exams coming up this
homeless man says he pulled nails and
shrapnel from the bodies of the wounded
I didn't know I wouldn't be able to live
with myself food for walking away and
sitting and leaving kids like our people
gave of themselves to long lines formed
outside blood banks filled by people
like Mazen you Dean time like this it
makes you realize
how valuable life is by Tuesday some of
Monday night's sorrows had been
transformed into a resolute sense of
civic pride always remember never forget
forever Manchester choose love
Manchester thank you
the Manchester United soccer team held a
practice yesterday where they had a
moment of silence they'll be playing
later today in Sweden and we're told
they'll be wearing black armbands as
their tribute continues Nora all right
Jonathan Vigliotti thank you so much